สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนักสวัสดีครับนักเรียนเยๆกลับมา
เจอกับครูอาตี้และครูพี่เอ๋ในช่อง
comprehensible ไยด้านนี้ด้านนี้โอเค้าน
ไหนโอคด้านบนโอเคครับผม
อ้าวันนี้เรามาเจอกันเอ่อวันอะไรครับวัน
นี้วันนี้เหรอคะอวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะอ่า
วันจันทร์ครับผมวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่ 18
เหมือนเดิมใช่ม 18 ค่ะใช่เนี่นะครับเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนนี้ใช่มยครับเดือนนี้เดือน
กรกฎาคมครับกรกฎาคมอปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศใช่
มั้ยพศพ.ศ
2565 พูดเองลืม
เองปีค.ศอะไรคะอ่าค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงอ้อตอน
นี้ใช่มั้ยครับอ่าตอนนี้ 20:00 นแล้วครับ
20 นเอ่อกี่นาทีครับเนี่ย 207 นใช่มั้ย
207 นนะอ่า 207 น 20:00 นครูอตี้ต้อง
เขียนเท่าไหร่ 20 ใช่
มั้อ่า 207 นโอเเราก็จะคุยกันจนถึง
2037 นอ่าแถวๆนี้ครับแถวๆนี้อื
โอเคนะคะอื
อืครูอาตี้ครับผมอ่าวันนี้เป็นไงบ้างครับ
สบายดี
เอ้อวันนี้สบายดีค่ะอ๋อสบายดีใช่มั้ยสบาย
ดีแต่ว่า 2-3 วันที่แล้วสบายไม่ดีอุ๊ยอ้า
ทำไมทำไม 2-3 วันที่แล้วไม่ดีเป็นอะไร
ครับฝนตกไงอ๋อฝนตกโอเคอือฝนตกคือฝนตกปั๊บ
เมื่อวันก่อนครูเอ๋มีปัญหาครูอาตี้อ๋อมี
ปัญหาอะไรครับตอนฝนตกมีปัญหาว่าเวลาฝนตก
แล้วมีอยู่วันนึงอ่ะค่ะฟ้าร้อง
เปรี้ยงฟ้าร้องคลืนืนแล้วก็มีฟ้าผ่า
เปรี้ยงครับครู
เอ๋ทำงานไม่ได้
อ๋อตอนที่ฟ้าผ่าครูเอ๋ก็ทำงานอยู่ใช่มย
อ่าแล้วพอฟ้าผ่าลงมาปั๊บทำงานไม่ได้เลย
เลยเกิดอะไรขึ้นครับทำไมทำไมทำงานไม่ได้
คือคืออะไรนะคือครูเอ๋ฟอะไรเนาแข็งค่ะคำ
ว่าแข็งคืออินเทอร์เน็ตอ่ะค่ะไม่ไม่ทำงาน
อ๋ออออินเทอร์เน็ตไม่ทำงานครูเอ๋กก็แข็ง
เลยใช่มั้ยครับค้างเลยกำลังคุยกับนัก
เรียนอยู่นักเรียนงงเอ๊ะทำไมครูเอ๋ไม่
ขยับใช่ครูเอ๋ก็เอ๊ะนักเรียนทำไมไม่ขยับ
นักเรียนบอกเอ๊ะทำไมครูเอ๋ไม่ขยับเอก็เลย
ต้องต้องปิดแล้วก็เปิดใหม่ออเข้ามาก็แข็ง
อีกอืมเข้าไม่ได้เหมือนเดิมใช่มั้ยใช่
สรุปว่าสอนไม่ได้อืสอนไม่ได้เพราะ
อินเทอร์เน็ตเสียหรอครับเอ่อมันช้าค่ะอ๋อ
มันช้ามันเป็นอย่างงี้มันดับไปก่อนครู
อาตี้อือฮึอ่าอินเทอร์เน็ตอ่ะครูเอก็เอ๊ะ
ทำไมใช่มั้ยคะทำไมแล้วก็เปิดมาก็ไม่มีก็
วิ่งไปดูใช่มั้ยคะก็เป็นสีแดงอ๋ออเป็นสี
แดงที่เราเตอร์เป็นสีแดงใช่มั้ยครับตัว
ไหนเคเรียกเราเตอร์อ่ะอ่าที่อินเทอร์เน็ต
เนี่ยเวลาที่มันเข้ามาที่บ้านเราเนี่ย
ครับมันจะมีเราเตอร์อยู่ก่อนที่จะเข้ามา
ที่คอมพิวเตอร์ของเราเดี๋ยวคูตี้มีรูป
เราเตอร์อยู่นี่ครับมันจะเข้ามาที่
เราเตอร์ตัวนี้อือ่าจะมีเอ่อสัญญาณ
อินเทอร์เน็ตจากจากเอ่อเสาเสา
อินเทอร์เน็ตใช่มั้ยเกูตีวาดรูปเสาก่อน
แล้วก็จะมีมีสายอินเทอร์เน็ตวิ่งเข้ามาใน
บ้านเราเข้ามาที่เราเตอร์ค่ะออของของเอก
ของครูเอกมี 2 ตัวอ๋อมี 2 ก็จะเป็นตัวที่
มีเสาแบบเนี้ย 1 แล้วก็มีตัวสี่เหลี่ยมดำ
ๆอีก 1 อ๋อโอเคอ่าก็จะมีอ่ะโอเคมันจะเข้า
มาที่เราเตอร์ตัวที่ 1 ก่อนค่ะอ่าตัวเ
เป็นเราเตอร์ปั๊บเอาสัญญาณเข้ามาที่นี่
แล้วจากตัวนี้ก็เข้ามาที่ตัวนี้ตัวนี้จะ
ทำหน้าที่ปล่อย WiFI ออ๋อใช่ๆๆ WiFi  WiFi
วาดยังไงอ้า WiFi ออกไปอย่างงี้อืปล่อย
WiFI เข้ามือถือเข้าไปที่
คอมพิวเตอร์อชั้น 2 ชั้นห้องอื่นได้ไม่
ต้องใช้สายไม่ต้องใช้สายแล้วเอครูอาตี้
ครูเอกขอถามหน่อยครับตัวเนี้ยเวลาเราจะ
นอนเราควรจะต้องปิดมยหรือไม่ต้องอ๋อไม่
ต้องปิดครับไม่ต้องปิดเปิดเ่อของคี้เปิด
ทั้งวันทั้งคืนเปิดตลอดเวลาเลยครับที่ครู
เอกถามครูเอกสงสัยว่าไอ้คลื่นของ WiFi
อ่ะจะมีผลกับร่างกาย
เรากัวที่ไม่คิดว่ามันจะมีอกเอแค่สงสัยนะ
คะอ๋อแต่ก็ก็ไม่ได้ปิดเหมือนกันค่ะไม่ได้
ปิดนะ
คะไม่ต้องปิดครับเริ่มคิดคิด
อะไรเอ๊ะนักเรียนปิดมั้ยคะเวลาจะนออ่าปิด
มยนักเรียนนักเรียนคอมเมนต์ให้ให้เรา
หน่อยนะคะว่านักอุ้ยนักเรียนปิด WiFi
ก่อนมั้ยคะเวลาจะนอนอ๋อแต่แต่เราปิด
โทรศัพท์ล่ะปิดคอมพิวเตอร์นะคะอื
คอมพิวเตอร์ปิดโทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์ครัวตี้ก็
ไม่ปิดนะอ้า
เหรอไม่ิดต้องไปไว้ข้างนอกไปไว้ข้างนอก
ใช่ๆไว้ในห้องนอนไม่ได้อ่าใช่ครับโอเคค่ะ
ทีนี้มันมันก็เอ่อวันนั้นน่ะเอ่อดับนะคะ
คือครูเอ๋ก็เลยต้องโทรศัพท์คุยกับนัก
เรียนอ่าโอเคนักเรียนคะอินเทอร์เน็ตใช้
ไม่ได้พรุ่งนี้นะอมาลืนนี้ก็
ได้ขอโทษค่ะแต่บางครั้งเอ่อของครัวตี้ถ่า
อินเทอร์เน็ตที่บ้านเสียเนี่ยใช้งานไม่
ได้คี้ก็จะใช้อินเทอร์เน็ตจากโทรศัพท์ได้
เหมือนกันอือ่าใช้อินเทอร์เน็ตจาก
โทรศัพท์เข้ามาในคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็สอนต่อ
ได้ใช่ไอค
ไงไม่ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ตอนนั้นน่ะไม่รู้แต่ตอน
เรู้แล้วสอตอนนี้รู้แล้วใช่มั้ยโอเคโอเคอ
สามีนั่งหัวเราะทำไมสอนไม่
ได้ครูอตี้ค่ะแล้วแล้วครูเอโทรไปโทรไปที่
โทรไปที่
เอ่อที่เเรียกว่าอะไรครับค่ายค่าย
อินเทอร์เน็ตใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ายอโทรไปมั้ยโทร
ไปมั้ยโทรๆรๆโทรไปเพราะว่าสีแดงหมดเลยอือ
ครูเอกก็โทรศัพท์ไปอ่าโทอ่า่ะครูเอ๋โทรมา
เดี๋ยวครูอตี้เป็นเ่อเป็นเจ้าหน้าที่เป็น
เจ้าหน้าที่ที่ค่ายอินเทอร์เน็ตให้อ่าโทร
มาเลยครับนักเรียนต้องรู้นะคะว่าครูเอ
เนี่ย low เทคโนโลยีมาก
ไม่รู้เรื่องเทคโนโลยีอเดี๋ยววันนี้คูตี้
จะเป็นเอ่อเจ้าหน้าที่ครับเป็นเจ้าหน้า
ที่เอ่อเอ่อเครือข่ายอินเทอร์เน็ตใช่ได้ๆ
ๆอ่าโทรมาเลยครับกตือ่าตื๊ดๆๆอ่าโอเค
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะอ่าโอเคบอรดแบนด
อินเทอร์เน็ตยินดีรับใช้ครับค่ะช่วยด้วย
ค่ะอ้าเป็นยังไงครับเน็ตไม่มีอ่ออ้าวเน็ต
ไม่มีเหรอครับค่ะฝนตกแล้วมีฟ้าผ่าเปรี้ยง
แล้วหายไปเลยค่ะตอนนี้ค่ะสัญาณไม่มีอ่ะ
ค่ะอ๋อโอเคถ้าอย่างงั้นขอเอ่อขอเลขที่ผู้
ใช้
บริการด้วยครับมีเลขที่ผู้ใช้บริการมั้ย
ครับอ่า Y  2526  8764 ค่ะอ๋อ Y  25  26
8764 เดี๋ยวขอผมเช็คแป๊บนึงนะครับได้ค่ะ
อ่าตึ๊ดๆๆๆอ๋อโอเค Y  2526
8764 นะครับอ่าเราไม่มีเลขหมายนี้ครับ
ห้ะลูกค้าใช้ใช้บริการค่ายไหน
ครับเอ๊อันนี้ที่ไหนค่ะอ่าอันนี้บริษัท
เอ่อบอดแบนอินเทอร์เน็ตไทยนครับออขอโทษ
ค่ะใช้ของอีกที่นึงค่ะอ๋อโอเคครับของ AIS
ค่ะโทษค่ะ AIS ใช่มโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวลูกค้า
โทรไปอีกเอ่อที่ AIS อีกครั้งหนึงนะครับ
ค่ะางสายครับตูดๆๆกี้ล้อเล่นครับล้อเล่น
ครับล้อเล่นอ่ะโอเคู้เอ๋โทรมาใหม่ครับที
นี้โทรมาใหม่อเอาใหม่เอา
ใหม่สวัสดีค่ะเบอร์นี้จริงๆค่ะเอ้ยไม่
ใช่สวัสดีครับอ่าโอเคเ่อ AIS บนยินดีรับ
ใช้ครับค่ะคืออินเทอร์เน็ตไม่สัญญาณหาย
อ่ะค่ะอ๋อสัญญาณหายใช่มั้ยครับอ่าตอนนี้
ที่เราเตอร์อ่าไฟสีเขียวติดกี่ดวงครับมี
แต่สีแดงค่ะอ๋อมีแต่สีแดงใช่มั้ยครับโอเค
ถ้าอย่างงั้น
เอ่อเดี๋ยวคุณลูกค้าคุณลูกค้าลองปิด
เราเตอร์นะครับปิดหรอคะอ่ามีปุ่มมีปุ่ม
ปิดอยู่ด้านหลังนะครับอ่าปุ่มสีดำๆกลมๆสี
ดำๆอ่าอยู่ด้านหลังของเครื่องครับกดเลย
ใช่มั้ยคะอ่ากดเลยครับกด 1 ครั้งครับกด
แล้วค่ะอ่าโอเคตอนนี้ไฟทุกดวงดับแล้วใช่
มั้ยครับดับหมดแล้วค่ะอ่าโอเคดีครับ
เดี๋ยวนะครับอ่าคุณลูกค้านับ 1-10 ครับ
ไม่ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10 หายใจ
เข้าหรอค่ะโอเคนับนึงถึง 10 แล้วกดเปิด
อีกครั้งนึงครับอ๋อโอเคค่ะกดเปิดแล้วค่ะ
โอเคอ่ะเดี๋ยวคุณลูกค้ารอแป๊บนึงนะครับ
ค่ะอ่าก็อ่าสังเกตไฟครับจะมีไฟเริ่มติด
ขึ้นมา 1 ดวงกระพริบกระพริบมีรครับใช่ค่ะ
มีค่ะกระพริบกระพริบค่ะอ่ากระพริบ 1 ดวง
โอเคเหมือนเหมือนกระพริบตาเนี่ยค่ะ
กระพริบอ่าใช่ครับกระพริบกระพริบอ 1 ดวง
แล้วใช่มดับสว่างดับสว่างใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะดวง
ที่ 2 ติดหรือยังครับติดแล้วค่ะอ่าติด
แล้วใช่มั้ยครับอ่าถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเอ่อคุณ
ลูกค้ารออีกแป๊บนึงครับอ่าจะมีไฟลอยู่ 1
ดวงที่มีสัญญาณเป็นสัญญาณ WiFi ครับไฟล
แบบนี้
ครับ
อ่าเป็นสัญญาณ WiFi จะเป็นแบบนี้นะค่ะ
โอเคอ่ะไฟสัญญาณ WiFi ติดหรือยังครับตอน
นี้อ๋อติดแล้วค่ะดวงที่ 3 ติดแล้วใช่มั้ย
ครับโอเคค่ะเป็นสีเขียวหรือเป็นสีส้มครับ
อ่าตอนนี้สีส้มอยู่ค่ะอ่าเป็นสีส้มอ่า
ต้องรอสักอีกแป๊บนึงครับค่ะอ้าเขียวแล้ว
ค่ะอ่าเขียวแล้วใช่มั้ยครับโอเคครับถ้า
งั้นเดี๋ยวคุณลูกค้าคุณลูกค้าลองลอง
เอ่อเปิดคอมพิวเตอร์ดูครับแล้วลองดูเ่อ
ลองเข้าอินเทอร์เน็ตดูครับ
ค่ะอ๋อเข้าแล้วค่ะแต่สัญญาณมีมี 2 ขีดอ่ะ
ค่ะอ๋อสัญญาณมี 2 ขีดตอนนี้เอ่อใช่ค่ะ
เอ่อตอนนี้เปิดหน้าเว็บแล้วช้ามากใช่มั้ย
ครับใช่หมุนค่ะอ๋อยังหมุนอยู่ยังไม่เข้า
ใช่มั้ยครับหมุปิ้วๆอยู่เลยค่ะเคโอเค
อาการนี้เป็นบ่อยมยครับ
อ่อช่วงนี้เป็นบ่อยอ่ะค่ะอ๋อเป็นเป็นบ่อย
ช่วงนี้ช่วงที่ฝนตกนี้ใช่มั้ยครับใช่อ๋อ
แต่ตอนตอนปกติแล้วเนี่ยคุณลูกค้าเอ่อมี
ปัญหาเกี่ยวกับสัญญาณอินเทอร์เน็ตช้ามั้ย
ครับ
อืมาแรกๆไม่ช้าแต่ตอนหลังๆเนี่ยช้าบ่อย
อ่ะค่ะอ๋อตอนนี้ช้าบ่อยมากใช่มั้ยครับใช่
อ่าโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวผมขอเช็คโปรโมชั่นที่คุณ
ลูกค้าใช้งานอยู่สักครู่นะครับได้ค่ะได้
ค่ะรอสายใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับรอสายสักครู่
นะครับค่ะรอสายอ่าตึงๆๆอ่าก็แล้วฟังเพลง
ฟังโฆษณาไปช่วงนี้ก็จะมีโฆษณาขึ้นมานะ
ครับอ่าโอเคครับอ่อขอบคุณมากที่ถือสายรอ
นะครับนะค่ะตอนนี้เอ่อผมเช็คโปรโมชั่นของ
คุณลูกค้าที่ใช้อยู่เนี่ยคุณลูกค้าใช้
โปรโมชั่นเอ่ออยู่ที่
250 ท 250 อยู่นะครับหืคืออะไรค่ะ 250
ก็คือความเร็วในการเอ่อในการดาวน์โหลด
millis  250  mbit  per  Second ครับ
อาฮะโอเคแล้วก็ความเร็วในการอัปโหลดอ่า
250 เบิต per  Second เหมือนกันอุ๊บขอ
พาราเซตามอนกลับได้มคโอก็คือตอนนี้
250/250 คือความเร็วในการเอ่อดาวน์โหลด
ข้อมูลในการเข้าเว็บค่ะแล้วก็ความเร็วใน
การอัปโหลดข้อมูลตอนที่เ่อลูกค้าส่ง
สัญญาณวีีดีโอไปหาเพื่อนออส่งสัญญาณเสียง
ไปหานักเรียนมันน้อยใช่มั้ยคะใช่ครับผม
คิดว่าผมคิดว่ามันค่อนข้างน้อยครับอ๋อ
แล้วต้องทำยังไงคะอ่าตอนนี้ตอนนี้ของ
บริษัทเรามีโปรโมชั่นอยู่พอดีครับเดี๋ยว
ผมเอ่อนำเสนอโปรโมชั่นให้กับอ่อคุณลูกค้า
นะครับคุณลูกค้าตอนนี้
เอ่อสามารถเข้าเว็บได้ใช่มั้ยครับแต่ช้า
ใช่มั้ยครับใช่ใช้เวลานานมากอ่าโอเคคุณ
ลูกค้าลองเข้าไปที่
www.ais เอ่อ internet  br  Band ครับ
โอเคค่ะอ่าเข้าไปที่นี่ครับคุณลูกค้าจะ
เห็นจะเห็นอ่าหน้าจอโปรโมชั่นอยู่ตรงนี้
ครับค่ะอ่าตอนนี้เห็นเห็นเอ่อหน้า
โปรโมชั่นของเรามั้ยครับ
อ่าสักครู่นะคะอ่าโอเคต้องต้องคลิกที่ตัว
ไหนนะคะอ่าเว็บไซต์โอเคนะคะอ่าเว็บไซต์
นี้ครับจะเห็นรูปนี้ค่ะอ่าตอนนี้
โปรโมชั่นที่คุณลูกค้าใช้ก็คือ
250  megabit  per  Second นะครับค่ะอัพ
250 ก็คือความเร็วในการอ่าดาวน์โหลดแล้ว
ก็อัปโหลดนะครับอ่าอันนี้จะเป็นดาวน์โหลด
อ่าอันนี้จะเป็นอัปโหลดค่ะอ่าอยู่ที่ความ
เร็วเท่านี้แต่ถ้าคุณลูกค้าต้องใช้งานใน
การเอ่อล Streaming คือส่งวดีโอนะครับส่ง
สัญญาณเสียงอยู่ตลอดเวลาเนี่ยค่ะค่ะต้อง
เอ่อผมใช Zoom ค่ะใช้ Zoom อยู่ออใช้ Zoom
ใช่มั้ครับอ่าผมแนะนำให้ใช้ความเร็วที่
500/500 นะครับจะดีมากครับแล้วมี
โปรโมชั่นอะไรบ้างคะทั้งหมดเนี่ยอ่าทั้ง
หมดก็จะมีตอนนี้ตอนนี้ที่มีโปรโมชั่นอยู่
ก็คือมี 400/400 นะความเร็วในการ
ดาวน์โหลดแล้วก็อัปโหลด
นะครับอ่า 400/400 เบิต per  Second เี่
จะอยู่ที่ 700 บาทต่อ 1 เดือนนะครับค่ะ
อ่าแต่ถ้าต้องการที่ความเร็วความเร็วมาก
กว่านั้นขึ้นไปอีกนะครับจะอยู่ที่
500/500 อนะครับเบิตราคาเท่าไหร่คะต่อ
เดือนอ่าอันนี้ราคา 900 บาทครับ 900 บาท
นะคะอ่าต่อ 1 เดือนนะครับอ๋อแล้วหมดแล้ว
ใช่มั้ยคะมีมากกว่านี้มั้คะอ่าถ้ามากกว่า
นี้ตอนนี้เอ่อสัญญาณที่เร็วที่สุดที่เรา
มีจะอยู่ที่ 1  gbit ครับค่ะ 1  gbit นะ
ครับในการดาวน์โหลดแล้วก็อัปโหลดเนี่ยจะ
อยู่ที่ 500 เบิตเหมือนกันค่ะราคาต่อ
เดือนเท่าไหร่คะราคาต่อเดือน 1,200 บาท
ครับ 1,200 บาทอ่าใช่ครับเอแต่ดูในเนี้ย
มีเค้าเขียนว่าฮอตเนี่ย
250 อ๋อ H  250 ก็คือตัวนี้เป็นตัวที่
ราคาถูกที่สุดสุดแล้วคนนิยมนิยมใช้แพคเกจ
นี้มากที่สุดครับอ๋อแต่ถ้ากรณีที่เราใช้
เอ่อวิดีโอมหรือว่าการอะไรนะอ่าถ้าไ
Streaming ก็ต้องการเอ่อความเร็วที่สูง
ขึ้นมาอีกครับค่ะอืก็คุณแนะนำที่เท่าไหร่
นะคะอ่าแนะนำที่
500/500 ครับอื
500/500 จะเร็วไม่สะดุดแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยคะ
อ่าจะไม่สะดุดแล้วครับอือฮึอ่าตอนนี้เรา
มีโปรโมชั่นเอ่อติดตั้งฟรีแล้วเราก็แถม
แถม
เราเตอร์ให้ฟรีด้วยนะครับต้องเปลี่ยน
เราเตอร์อันนี้ออกเหรอคะอ่าถ้าเป็น
เราเตอร์ตัวเก่าคุณลูกค้าใช้เราเตอร์ตัว
นี้มานานหรือยังครับ 3 ปีค่ะออถ้า 3 ปีผม
แนะนำให้ใช้เราเตอร์ตัวใหม่ที่เราจะแถม
ให้ฟรีดีกว่าครับอ๋อไม่ต้องเสียเงินเพิ่ม
อไม่ต้องเสียเงินเพิ่มครับตอนนี้โปรโชร
เราเตอร์ครับอ๋อแล้วเ่อแล้วเอ่ออะไรนะถ้า
เกิดพี่อะไรนะสมัครใช่มั้ยคะครับอ่าถ้า
สมัครโปรโมชั่น 900 บาทเนี่ยต้องสัญญา
เนี่ยต้องเป็นสัญญานานเท่าไหร่คะอ๋อสมัคร
900 บาทตอนนี้ใช่มั้ยครับก็เอ่อใช้งาน
ต้องใช้งานต่อเนื่องกันเป็นเวลา 12 เดือน
ครับก็คือ 1 ปีอ่า 1 ปีใช่ครับอ๋อ 1 ปีนะ
คะ 1 ปีคุณลูก 900 บาท 900 บาท 1 ปีอ่า
ใช่ครับ 900 บาท 1 ปีนะครับอ่าก็เป็นเป็น
เป็นตัว
สัญญาอได้ค่ะได้ค่ะเพราะพี่ต้องใช้งานอ๋อ
อ่าดีครับงั้นก็เอาที่ 900 บาทค่ะอ่าโอเค
ได้ครับถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเ่อผมใช้ฐานข้อมูล
เดิมของคุณลูกค้าที่มีอยู่กับผมนะครับอ่า
แล้วเอ่อคุณลูกค้ายังใช้เบอร์โทรศัพท์ติด
ต่อเป็นเบอร์เดิมั้ครับเบอร์เดิมค่ะออ
โอเคเบอร์เดิมนะครับเดี๋ยวอีก 2 วันจะมี
เจ้าหน้าที่โทรกลับไปหาลูกค้านะครับค่ะ
ได้ค่ะเพื่อที่จะนัดเวลาติดตั้งครับว่า
คุณลูกค้าสะดวกวันไหนครับค่ะอ๋อแต่พี่ไม่
ต้องระบุตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับยังไม่
ต้องบอกน้องใช่มคยังไม่ต้องบอกตอนนี้ครับ
เพราะว่าเดี๋ยวจะมีทีทีมอีกทีมหนึ่งอ่า
เป็นทีมช่างทีมช่างถ้าเขาไปในบริเวณเอ่อ
ใกล้ๆกับบ้านของคุณลูกค้าเขาจะโทรหาลูก
ค้าว่าเ่อวันนี้สะดวกมยอหรือว่าพรุ่งนี้
สะดวกกี่โมงเขาจะประสานงานกับลูกอีกนาน
มั้ยคะอ่าประมาณ 2 วันครับ 2 วันนะคะอ่า
ใช่ครับ 2 วันค่ะแล้วน้องทำเรื่องยื่นไป
ทางช่างให้ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับเดี๋ยวผม
จัดการทุกอย่างให้เรียบร้อยเลยครับอ่ะ
น้องชื่อชื่ออะไรคะอ่าเอ่อผมชื่ออาตี้
ครับอาตี้เอ่อพี่โทรมาเบอร์นี้คือคุยกับ
น้องอาร์ตี้ได้เลยใช่มั้ยเอ่อถ้าถ้า
สมมุติช่างไม่โทรมาหาพี่ครับอ๋ออ่ะโทร
เข้ามาที่เบอร์นี้เหมือนเดิมแล้วก็แจ้ง
แจ้งชื่อคุณลูกค้าเหมือนเดิมครับแล้วเขา
ทุกคนจะทราบเรื่องว่าเอ่อคุณลูกค้าติดต่อ
กับใครเรื่องอะไรอยู่ครับอ๋อพี่ไม่ต้อง
บอกว่าติดต่อกับอาตี้อ่าใช่ครับไม่ต้อง
ครับเพราะว่าว่าบางครั้งแล้วเนี่ยเอ่อผม
อาจจะไม่ได้ทำงานในช่วงที่คุณลูกค้าโทรมา
อออ่าใช่ครับโอเคขอบคุณค่ะงั้นพี่ขอ
เปลี่ยนเป็นที่อ่าโปรโมชั่น 900 ค่ะ
โปโมชั่น 900 บาทนะครับโอเคครับขอบคุณที่
ใช้บริการ AIS  Broadband อินเทอร์เน็ต
ครับขอบคุณค่ะอ่าครับผมขอบคุณมากครับ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะอ่า
โอเคใช่ค่ะนักเรียนค่ะคุยอย่างนี้เลยค่ะ
แบบนี้เลยครับหน้าตาคุ
ปเออหน้าตาครูเอ๋ก็บแต่บางทีนะครูอาตี้
บางทีครูเอ๋โทรไปเนี่ยแล้วเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
ก็บอกบอกบอกชื่อเค้าบอกรหัสเค้าเสร็จเบอก
อ๋อเน็ตช้าอยู่ใช่มั้ย
คะเเจะรู้เลยเพราะว่าบางทีบางทีเหมือนกับ
ที่เซ็นเตอร์เ้ามีเมีตัวเช็คอะไรก็ไม่
ทราบเก็บอกอ๋อเมื่อกี้เมื่อเกิดอเกิดอะไร
นะฝนตกฟ้าร้องบริเวณนั้นอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อ๋ออืๆหรือไม่บางทีอาจจะมีคนโทรไปเยอะก็
ได้ครูเอกก็อ่าใช่ๆบางทีก็มีคนโทรไปเยอะ
เขาก็รู้ว่าออคนนี้คนที่โทรมาเอ่อเจ้า
หน้าที่เขาจะรู้ว่าคนที่โทรมาเวลาบอกบอก
เลขหมายไปแล้วเจะรู้ว่าคนเนี้ยบ้านอยู่
ตรงไหนค่ะอ่าแล้วถ้ามีคนที่อยู่แถวๆนั้น
น่ะโทรมาแล้วเคก็อ้อนี่อยู่ใกล้ๆกันเลยเค
รู้เรู้เก็ก็จะบอกอ่าตอนนี้อ่าอะไรนะอ่า
อ่ากดเปิดแล้วปิดใหม่ครับแล้วก็ส่งส่ง
สัญญาณ
ให้เออนะคะเก็แจ้งได้นะคะแจ้งอ่าใช่ครับ
ใช่ครับนะคะอือ่ะ 2 วันผ่านไปอ่า 2 วัน
ผ่านไปนะครับวันที่ 2 วันที่ 2 นะเดี๋ยว
ผมโทรไป
อ
ออดอดเสียงโทรศัพท์หรือเสียงออนฮะโอเค
เอ๊ะเบอร์ใครอ่าๆๆๆๆจะหล่นอฮะสวัสดีค่ะ
อ่าสวัสดีครับอ่าคุณลูกค้าครับอ่าจากไหน
คะอ่า
เอ่อจากบริษัท AIS อิเตอร์เน็ตบอด Band
ครับอ๋อค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่าโอเคคุณลูกค้าทำ
เรื่องเอ่อติดตั้งอินเทอร์เน็ตโปรโมชั่น 9
เอ่อ 900 บาท 500/500 ไว้ใช่มั้ยครับใช่
ค่ะอ่าโอเคเอ่อเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้ผม
จะเข้าไปเ่อในบริเวณเอ่อใกล้ๆกับบ้านของ
ลูกค้าคุณลูกค้าสะดวกให้ผมเข้าไปติดตั้ง
เลยมั้ครับออได้ค่ะแต่ขอเป็นช่วงบ่ายได้
มั้ยคะอ๋อช่วงบ่ายใช่มั้ยครับโอเคช่วง
บ่ายช่วงเช้าพี่ทำงานอือฮึก็จะมีเวลา
14:00
นได้โอเคเอ่อผมจะใช้เวลาประมาณ 2 ชมงคุณ
ลูกค้าเอ่อสะดวกมครับ 2 ชมเอ่อ 13:00 น
บ่าย 14:00 น 15  15:00 น 1600 นอ่า 2 น
ถึง 16:00 นคุณลูกค้าสะดวกมั้ยครับได้ค่ะ
ได้ค่ะอ๋ออ่าโอเคได้ครับถ้าอย่างั้นน้อง
เข้ามาก็ของพี่เป็นคอนโดนะคะครับผมเป็น
คอนโดก็บอกบอกข้างล่างจะมียามครับนะก็บอก
เค้าว่ามาห้องเอ่อ 61 ค่ะอ่าห้อง 61 นะ
ครับอยู่ชั้นไหนครับคุณลูกค้าอยู่ชั้น 5
ค่ะอ๋อชั้น 5 นะครับห้อง 61 อผมแจ้งชื่อ
คุณลูกค้าที่เอ่อที่ยามแล้วก็ที่มิติได้
เลยค่ะอ๋อโอเคอ่าได้ครับเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้
14:00 นผมเข้าไปนะครับค่ะได้ค่ะกเข้ามา
ก็แจ้งที่นิติแล้วโทรหาพี่ก่อนได้เดี๋ยว
เดี๋ยวพี่พี่ลงไปรับขึ้นมาอ๋อโอเคได้ครับ
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้เอ่อเข้าไปแล้วผมโทรหานะ
ครับได้ค่ะนะโอเคขอบคุณค่ะครับผมยินดี
ครับขอบคุณที่ใช้บริการครับสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีค่ะ
อือ
โอเคเหมเหมือนคุยโทรศัพท์จริงๆเลยนั่นน่ะ
สิโทรศัพท์ไปทำไมยกมาทำไมใช้ไมค์อยู่โอเค
โอเคอ่ามแบบกำลังคุยจริงอินเทอร์เน็ตเรา
ก็โอเค
เอ่ออ่าก็เป็นการนัดหมายนะครับแล้วก็บอก
ความต้องการของเราว่าเราสะดวกตอนไหนนะ
ว่างหรือเปล่าใช่เวลาใช้เเ่าไหร่อือฮึค
แล้วก็ก่อนที่เาจะเข้ามาจริงๆอ่ะครับ
สมมติว่าพรุ่งนี้ใช่มั้ยคะครับก่อนเข้ามา
เนี่ยเ่อช่างก็จะโทรหาเราอีกรอบนึงใช่ใช่
ครับเเรียกว่าจะโทรมามามาโทรมานัดก่อนโทร
มานัดก่อนว่าอยู่หรือเปล่าหรือโทรมาบอก
ให้เตรียมตัวเตรียมตัวก่อนจะเข้าไปแล้วนะ
ใช่เราอาจจะแบบนอนแล้วเพิ่ง
ตื่นเก็จะบอกว่าอ่าสวัสดีสวัสดีครับอีก
อ่ะๆครูอตี้เป็นช่างวันพรุ่งนี้ออังวัน
พรุ่งนี้มาถึงแล้วใช่มั้ยครับใช่โอเค
[เพลง]
อ่าตื๊ดๆๆดๆๆตืดตืดสวัสดีค่ะอสวัสดีครับ
จากไหนคะอ่าจาก a บอแบรนด์ครับผมอ่าตอน
นี้ผมอยู่ข้างล่างแล้วครับเดี๋ยวๆๆๆช่าง
เขจะโทรมาก่อนครึ่งชั่วโมงอโทรมาก่อน
ครึ่ง
ชั่วโมงโอเคช่างมาเร็วอ่ะโอเคช่างมารอ
จริงๆช่างว่างตั้งแต่เช้าแล้วแต่กูเออ๋
บอกให้โทรบบอกว่าว่าง 14:00 นอ๋อบางที
ช่างเขาจะบอกมาก่อนว่าเดี๋ยวอีกครึ่ง
ชั่วโมงมาถึงนะหรืออะไรอย่างเงี้ยโอเค
โอเคอ่าสวัสดีครับอ่ะครู่เออ๋ใช่มั้ครับ
ใช่ครับค่ะอ่าที่นัทติดตั้งอินเทอร์เน็ต
ไว้นะครับตอน 14:00 นนะครับค่ะอ่าใช่ครับ
อีกประมาณครึ่งชั่วโมงผมจะเข้าไปถึงนะ
ครับได้ค่ะได้ค่ะโอเคเดี๋ยวเข้าไปถึงแล้ว
ผมจะเอ่อรอที่นิติบุคคลนะครับได้ค่ะแล้ว
โทรมาหาพี่นะเดี๋ยวพี่ลงไปรับอ่าโอเคได้
ครับขอบคุณครับแล้วเจอกันนะครับค่าสวัสดี
ค่ะครับสวัสดีครับคือคือเค้าว่าจะโทรมา
เพื่อให้เราเตรียมตัวก่อน
ค
เผื่อเรายังไม่พร้อมเสื้อผ้าอะไรอย่างงี้
อ๋ออ่าเผื่อยังไม่ตื่นด้วยมีนะมีนะครูเอ๋
นะตอนบ่ายนะคะดตอนบ่ายแล้วก็ทำนู่นนี่
เสร็จประมาณ 11:00 นลงไปช่างช่างนั่งรอ
อยู่ข้าง
หลังมาเป็นมาเป็นทีมเลยค่ะมาเป็นทีมเอ่อ
คือวันวันที่ติดตั้งวันแรกอ่ะมา 3 คน 4
คนกูเอกก็ตกใจโอ๊มาแล้วเบอกไม่เป็นไรครับ
มีเวลานั่งรอครูเอกก็เลยบอกหัวนี่ยังอยู่
อย่างเงี้ยโอเคยังไม่พร้อมใช่มั้ยยังไม่
พร้อมให้ติดตั้งโอเคไม่เป็นไรค่ะน้องขึ้น
เลยทำเลยอ่ามาแล้วก็ทำเลยจะได้ไม่เสีย
เวลาใช่มั้ยใช่มาแล้วทำเลยนะฮะก็เลยบอก
น้องน้องน้องโทรบอกพี่ก็ได้ถ้าถ้ามาถึง
เร็วนะฮะออคือคือวันนั้นว่างนะคะวันนั้น
ว่างแต่ถ้าวันไหนที่ไม่ว่างอ่ะก็จะต้อง
บอกเา้าว่าให้ให้มาช่วงเวลานี้นะอ่าครับ
นะเราก็สามารถบอกเขาได้ครับว่าจะเราสะดวก
ตอนไหนเราว่างตอนไหนบอกได้นะครับใช่พอพอเ
ขึ้นมาถึงในที่บ้านเราเก็จะถามเราว่าเอ่อ
เราตั้งเราเตอร์ไว้ตรงไหนอ่าใช่ครับอจะ
วางเตอรไว้ตรงไหนครับอือือฮึเราก็พาเ้าไป
พาเ้าไปดูใช่มั้ยคะว่าอยู่ตรงไหนอ่าเค้า
ก็จะดูแล้วเคก็จะจะการถอดให้อ่าใช่ครับพอ
เค้าทำเสร็จหมดเรียบร้อยแล้วเาจะให้เราทำ
อะไรคะครูอาตี้อ่าเขาคก็อ้าเดี๋ยวคุณลูก
ค้าลองเทสสัญญาณนะครับค่ะอ่าลองเปิด
คอมพิวเตอร์ครับแล้วก็เช็คนะครับอ่าลอง
เปิดมือถือครับอ่ามีสัญญาณมั้ยถือเอคอ่า
คุณลูกค้าอยากเอ่อใช้
User ตั้ง User  User ใหม่มยครับได้ค่ะ
ได้ค่ะอ่าโอเคใช้ User รหัสอะไรอะไรดี
ครับคุณลูค้าจดใส่จดใส่กระดาษให้ผมก็ได้
ครับโอเคอ่าหรือบอกมาก็ได้ครับเดี๋ยวผม
เอ่อเปลี่ยนเป็น A  2
25  25  2  25  25 ได้มั้ยคะอ๋อโอเค
เปลี่ยนเป็น a25  25  2 นะครับแล้วลจะได้
จำง่ายๆอ่าโอเค 25  25  3 ครั้งนะครับ
แล้วใช้รหัสอะไรดีครับรหัสเหรอคะอ่าขอ
รหัส 4 หลักครับมีตัวอักษรด้วยครับ
อ่า
A  2  25
2 อาฮะ a  252 ค่ะอ่า A  2  52 แล้วก็ 25
2  4 ตัวสิอโอเค 4 หลักอ่ะโอเคได้ครับ
อ่ะคุณลูกค้าใช้รหัสนี้นะครับทุกครั้งที่
เอ่อเชื่อมต่อกับอินเทอร์เน็ตนะครับโอเค
ลูกค้าต้องจดไว้ด้วยนะครับจดไว้ด้วยนะ
ครับเผื่อลืมนะครับลูกค้าลืมประจำคุณลูก
ค้าจดไว้ด้วยนะครับจดรหัสไว้ด้วยนะครับ
ลูกค้าลืม
ค่ะโอเคของครัวตี้จะจดไว้ที่ตัวเราเตอร์
จดแล้วก็ติดไว้ที่เราเตอร์อ๋อเหรอเน็ต
หลุดนี่หายใช่เวลาลูกถามเวลาลูกถามหรือ
เวลามีแขกมาบ้านมีแขกมาบ้านครูตี้ก็บอก
อ่าบอกรหัสอะไร WiFi ัอะไรอ่าใช่ครับวัน
ก่อนเพื่อนมารหัสอะไรเออไม่รู้สามีไม่
อยู่ด้วยต้องจดจดแล้วแปะไว้ที่เราเตอร์
ครับไม่ลืมแน่นอนโอเคได้ค่ะนักเรียนครู
เอ๋นี่บ้าๆบอๆ
นัโอเคคุณลูกค้าใช้งานได้ปกติแล้วเดี๋ยว
ผมขอตัวกลับเลยนะครับอ่าขอบคุณต้องเซ็น
อะไรมยคะอ่าต้องเซ็นเอ่อรับงานด้วยครับ
โอเคก็เซ็นรับงานแล้วก็ต้องเซ็นนะคะเจะ
ให้เราเซ็นมีกระดาษแต่บางที่ก็ไม่เป็น
กระดาษเป็น iPad มาอ่าใช่ครับเซ็นใส่ลงไป
ใน iPad ค่ะหรือบางคนก็ให้เซ็นในโทรศัพท์
ก็ได้นะคะออเซ็นชื่อว่างานเรียบร้อยโอเ
อ่าใช้งานได้นะครับอค่ะอื
โอเคอินเทอร์เน็ตเร็วแล้วตอน
นี้ยเน็ตไม่สะดุดแล้วใช่มยตอนนี้ดีไม่
สะดุดแล้วค่ะไม่สะดุดแล้ว 900 บาทค่ะ 900
บาทครับไม่แพงครับค่ะไม่แพงโอเคค่ะโอเคอ
วันนี้เวลาเราหมดพอดีครับพี่เอใช่นัก
เรียนก็จะรู้ว่าเวลาจากโทรศัพท์คุยติดต่อ
เรื่องเน็ตช้าใช่ครับอ่าหรือว่าติดตั้ง
อินเทอร์เน็ตใหม่นะครับอ่าก็ทำยังไงโอเค
ป่ะอเราเอวันนี้ครูอตี้แล้วก็ครูพี่เอ๋นะ
ครับต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับแล้วเดี๋ยวคราว
หน้าเราจะมีเอ่อเหตุการณ์อะไรสนุกๆหรือ
การติดต่อประสานงานกับใครเดี๋ยวค่อยติด
ตามกันในคร่าวนะใช่เราค่อยไปดูว่าเออเรา
มีปัญหาอะไรมีธุระ
อะไรมีธุระดีกว่าครับไม่อยากมีปัญหาเลยอ
มี
ธุระมีธุระอะไรนะคะออโอเคค่ะโอเคครับวัน
นี้ลาไปก่อนแล้วครับอ่าสวัสดีครับพี่เอก๋
สวัสดีค่ะอ่าสวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนบ๊าย
บาย